salut comment vous allez est-ce que vous
allez bien aujourd'hui tout se passe
bien pour vous j'espère ça se passe bien
d'ailleurs du club en commentaire
aujourd'hui je viens vous parler d'apple
j'ai pas bien vous parlez d'une seule
machine gmi ont parlé de deux machines
mais je viens surtout vous parler de la
nouvelle
les premières puces d'apple dédiée sur
les ordinateurs c'est la puce
m un apple avait déjà annoncé il ya
quelques mois travaillé sur une puce
dédiée pour leur ordinateur que c'est la
fin de la collaboration intel apple pour
les processeurs il est donc cette toute
nouvelle pub d'un nouveau genre qui
vient d'arriver c'est cette puce et man
moi je les ai aussi présente sur deux
machines c'est le mac mini qui est juste
ici caché juste en dessous sur mon
macbook pro 13 pouces qui est situé
juste là vous pouvez également la voir
sur le nouveau macbook air et la gamme
va continuer à évoluer en 2021 donc on
en reparlera vous invite donc à venir
vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait
on va donc aujourd'hui parler de cette
nouvelle puce
au travers de ces deux produits je
voulais détails et je peux vous
expliquer je vais vous parler des usages
mois usage principal que j'ai chez apple
c'est le montage montage vidéo vous le
voyez ici j'ai failli d'accueil pro qui
est un logiciel édité par apple qui a
été complètement mis à jour peut être
optimisé avec cette nouvelle puce m1 et
vous allez voir le truc est quand même
assez dingue c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo
qui est réalisé en partenariat avec
intego quand on achète un nouveau mac
quand même bien devenir le protéger pour
éviter les déconvenues
je vais donc vous présenter la solution
mac internet security x9 d'illégaux qui
regroupe deux produits le virus barrière
x 9 vient protéger votre mac contre les
virus contre les malwares qui pourraient
traîner sur internet vous bénéficiez
leur base de données mise à jour
antiviral et il viendra à se caler votre
mac pour voir si des logiciels
malveillants se trouve à l'intérieur
peut bien réalisé mais email mais
également mon iphone et mon ipod touch
ou mon ipad mais également mes disques
durs externes lors d'une analyse
complète
il me demande quel type de logiciel
détecte et des malwares windows linux
script malveillant des outils de
piratage également des petits longueur
et se souvenir également ici planifier
mes analyses et bonne nouvelle avec
virus barrière vous êtes également
protégés sur macos beach meymac internet
security x9 comporte également un
pare-feu saynètes barrière x9 la houle
pare-feu présente nativement dans votre
mac vous protège des connexions
entrantes nez de barrières x9 vous
protège des connexions entrantes mais
également des connexions sortantes c'est
à dire que c'est vous qui a donné des
autorisations aux
ferrand programme qui situe dans votre
ordinateur on venir se connecter à
internet vous allez donc garder le
contrôle
et ça c'est rassurant je peux choisir
d'activer les connexions entrantes
connexions sortantes et de mettre des
exceptions afin d'avoir un profil
personnalisé en fonction des lieux où je
me trouve et j'ai accès ici à toutes mes
applications qui sont connectés à
internet je vois exactement ce qui se
passe en temps réel ça permet de tout
monitorer comme ça pas de mauvaise
surprise
bonne nouvelle également avec intego
vous pouvez protéger votre mac mais
également votre pc vous invite donc à
venir découvrir mac internet security x9
je vous ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description pour profiter de conditions
extrêmement intéressante
on a commencé par le macbook pro alors
ce macbook pro il est assez surprenant
pas par ce design parce que le design
c'est exactement le même qu'on
retrouvait sur les anciens macbook pro
13 pouces
je dirais de génération intel pas
d'anciennes générations parce que
c'était renouveler n'ya pas longtemps on
va voir rexie sur le côté uniquement
deux ports thunderbolt hearts et de
l'usb c'est une prise jack qui situé de
l'autre côté
l'écran est toujours très bien calibrée
très très bien maîtrisée de la part
d'apple expérience aussi super haut
niveau de l'audio bonne spatialisation
le magic qui bordent est super agréable
à utiliser on a surtout un très très
grand trackpad
on a la tchatche barre sur le dessus
touch haïti pour venir déverrouiller on
retrouve toujours une webcam en 720p
ici pas de 1080p c'est un peu dommage
par contre ce qui est intéressant et
c'est notamment dû grâce à cette
nouvelle puce emv bien chronique du 720p
la qualité est supérieure la qualité est
optimisé au niveau de cette webcam grâce
justement à la performance et à
l'intelligence artificielle qu'on peut
retrouver au travers de cette puce
m autre grosse nouveauté ce sont les
micros qualité studio qui vont vraiment
venir augmenter l'expérience notamment
pour du télétravail pour de la
collaboration donc l' enveloppe globale
reste sensiblement la même même si elle
est améliorée côté logiciel on trouve
mac os big four qui est le dernier os
pour mac qui fonctionne bien qui apporte
son lot de nouveautés et qui
fonctionnera vraiment bien en tandem
avec la puce et mode apple avant de vous
parler de cette puce et main et de mon
expérience avec le macbook pro 13 pouces
je vous parlais du mac mini
alors vous le voyez derrière moi ici
j'ai un pro x derrière display c'est un
peu surdimensionné par rapport aux mac
mini le mac mini m'a été prêté par apple
je n'avais pas de moniteur externe ici
j'en ai un
studio à paris je ne suis pas à paris
puisque le seul faisons confinement donc
apple va gentiment prêté un pro display
il libère que je n'avais jamais testé
que j'ai pu découvrir et que je trouve
vraiment vraiment vraiment incroyable
c'est pas celui qui va être recommandée
avec un mac mini comme le macbook pro 13
pouces le design reste vraiment
identique par rapport aux autres
générations de mac mini côté connectique
on a deux ports thunderbolt roi en usb 4
ports ethernet gigabit une prise jack
3.5 de l'âge des mythes 2.0 et deux
ports usb
nouveauté sur le mac mini on va
retrouver du wifi 6 vous avez une config
de base en 8 gigas de ram pouvait monter
jusqu'à saisir g et vous avez des
configs en 256 go de stockage 512
intérêt à monter jusqu'à 2 terrain vous
avez acheté le magic qui bordent
en plus ça joue le conseil parce que
sinon vous n'aurez pas que l'année ce
serait un petit peu de mal donc les
magic qui bordent qui fonctionne très
très bien également la magic mouse 2 et
le magic trackpad 2 qui est aussi très
cool alors en fonction de vos usages
on a donc deux produits qui sont
similaires d'un point de vue extérieur
mais la vraie grosse nouveauté la grosse
différence se situe à l'intérieur c'est
cette nouvelle puce et man 2 apple
la première chose à savoir sur cette
puce c'est que l'architecturé vraiment
différente de celle de intel ici on a
une architecture arm pour faire très
simple c'est la même architecture que
vous allez retrouver sur les ipad et sur
les iphone ce qui permet de faire
tourner les applications d' ipad mais
également d' iphone sur ses ordinateurs
là ça va devenir élargir le nombre
d'applications disponibles sur vos mac
ça laisse le champ libre aux
développeurs ont créé des applications
sans pour son écosystème apple ça c'est
pendant une des grosses nouveautés et
une des grosses clefs de voûte qu'on va
retrouver dans l'écosystème d'apple dans
les années à venir
imaginez c'est vraiment la perspective
et la promesse qu'ils aient fait ses
développeurs s'en rend pas c'est
vraiment le fait d'avoir une seule et
même application vous allez pouvoir
utiliser aussi bien sur votre ipod ou
votre iphone que sur votre mac
on va pas dans les mêmes performances
derrière on va imaginer qu'elle va
pouvoir s'adapter mais ça laisse en tout
cas entre apercevoir des usages qui
pourrait être extrêmement pertinent
l'avenir passons cette partie là la
promesse qui est fait ici par apple
c'est d'avoir un bien de performance et
un gain d'autonomie
c'est vrai que sur le papier quand apple
nous en parle on se dit ok ça a l'air
plutôt bien comment est-ce qu'ils vont
réussir à venir se positionner par
rapport à intel qu'un des acteurs
majeurs sur le marché aussi bien du
processeur sur mac du processeur sur pc
ils ont une expertise qui est assez
incroyable
ok sur le papier on s'attendait à voir
une puce qui soit aussi bien que celles
et bien c'est assez incroyable au delà
de retrouver une puce qui était aussi
bien et aussi fonctionnel que celle d'
intel on se retrouve ici avec une puce
qui dégomme intel en performance
littéralement
elle est beaucoup plus performante et
elle apporte en tout beaucoup plus
d'autonomie
je vais commencer par l'autonomie parce
que ces trucs un peu un peu on voit où
pour moi autonomie sur le mac mini autre
affiche un petit peu parce qu'ils ont
dévoré sur le secteur en permanence ça
nous intéresse davantage pour les
macbook pro et macbook air à l'umt à mon
petit lapin là à mon arrivée à peu près
à peu près à 10 heures entre 8 et 10
heures sur un macbook pro avec le
processeur de intel grâce à la puce et
main on vient doubler l'autonomie on va
pas rajouter 15% 20%
on vient là doublé puis pas si vous vous
rendez compte du gap c'est juste
incroyable
on approche les 20 heures 18 20 heures
d'autonomie c'est absolument démentielle
et là je vous parle que l'autonomie on
va parler de performance sur le macbook
pro 13 pouces apple nous annonce des
performances au niveau du processeur 2 x
8 plus rapide et jusqu'à cinq fois plus
performant au niveau graphique
autant vous dire que ça c'est dingue
alors j'ai pas réussi à mesurer le 2 x 8
plus rapide et le x 5 en termes de
performances graphiques mais par contre
que j'ai pu mesurer c'est la capacité de
calcul et la rapidité de calcul au
niveau de fanaye cut pro qu'étant
logiciels que j'utilise tous les jours
et depuis des années ça va beaucoup plus
vite comme je vous le disais faux n'y a
que deux protêts logiciel qui est édité
par apple qui a été mis à jour justement
pour cette nouvelle puce
on reste donc dans un système qui est
extrêmement bien calibré bien maîtrisée
par apple c'est plus seulement elle fait
une promesse qui assez dingue et surtout
elle la tient et c'est vraiment
démentiel c'est un peu frustrant pour
moi c'est que travaille sur un macbook
pro 16 pouces qui est vraiment super qui
est sorti l'année dernière
j'imagine qu'une mise à jour du macbook
pro 13 pouces avec les puces et main
l'année prochaine mais l'allemagne pro
13 pouces je n'ai utilisé je les ai
essayé mais c'est par la machine de tous
les jours donc à une vraie différence et
je suis devant la rend extrêmement
rapidement dans le body hamas j'ai goûté
un truc qui assez dingue et qui est très
performant et là je dois venir changer
en plus moi j'utilise mon macbook pro
comme je vous le dis tous les jours et
la batterie elle vient vraiment
descendre des sens lorsqu'il faial que
tu fais des rendus donc l'autonomie
elles baissent tout de suite aujourd'hui
je suis beaucoup moins déplacement à
cause du confinement mais lorsque je
travaillais dans un train par exemple
d'acheter toujours au mieux le dire
branchés sont les moments de rendu là
avec le nouveau macbook pro 13 pouces et
prend
humblement pu table vous demandons aux
pros ces secousses mais ça on en
reparlera en 2021
je n'aurai pas besoin d'emprunter sur le
secteur aussi rapidement si vous
envisagez de changer votre ordinateur
donne anciens malgré un nouveau mac ou
d'un pc vers un mac vers cette nouvelle
puce m 1 soyez rassurés parce que si les
développeurs vos applications n'ont pas
encore développé leur programme pour
l'architecturé arm sont toujours sur
l'architecturé intel et bien un peu là
tout prévu avec un émulateur qui
s'appelle rosetta qui a pouvoir faire
tourner vos anciens programmes sur cette
nouvelle machine
ça marche très très bien et moi
j'utilise des programmes d'hadopi son
photoshop lightroom
j'imagine que lorsque les programmes
seront vraiment optimisé pour la puce
est mince et emmènera encore plus loin
dans l'expérience mais déjà comme il est
là tuez vous assurer que ça marche super
bien je donne le tarif de ces machines
et vous mais les liens dans la
description pour aller jeter un coup
d'oeil ça vous intéresse macbook pro 13
pouces en version 8 gigas de ram plus
256 go de stockage écoute 1449 euros et
la version 8 gigas de ram 512 il ya de
stockage coûte 1679 euros et si vous
regardez le mac mini mac mini seuls sont
les accessoires sont le moniteur sur
rien du tout il coûte en version us giga
de ram 256 giga de stockage 799 euros et
8 gigas de ram 512 ya de stockage 1029
euros alors truc qui est assez dingue là
dessus c'est combattez tarifs ils sont
maintenus et sont surtout moins chère
que la rrq book pro 13 pouces version
intel
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucun intérêt à
venir acheter neuf sur le catalogue
d'apple ou ailleurs un macbook pro 13
pouces avec une puce intel puisque
l'avenir chez apple c'est la puce et
main et qu'ils sont moins chers que les
macbook pro 13 pouces avec la puce
d'intel
on aurait pu s'attendre à ce que apple
baisse les prix de ses macbook pro 13
pouces avec la puce intel en disant ok
on va baisser un peu pour venir les
écouler non ils adoptent une stratégie
contraire les nouveaux mac avec la puce
m1 coûtent moins chers sont très
accessibles pour tout le monde vienne
dessus qu'est ce qu'il adviendra de ces
mac avec ses plus d'une telle à l'avenir
peut-être qu'apple baissera les prix un
peu plus tard pour écouler les stocks
mais aujourd'hui ce qui est sûr ce qui
met le paquet sur cette nouvelle puce et
main moi je suis vraiment surpris par le
résultat
on aurait pu espérer avoir des
un petit peu retravaillé je pense
qu'apple n'a pas voulu complètement
changé sa copie pour rassurer le
consommateur en tout cas pour moi c'est
vraiment une très très belle découverte
super beau boulot très très très belle
avancée j'ai hâte de découvrir le
nouveau mac version 2021 et notamment le
macbook pro 16 pouces que je me ferais
un plaisir d'utiliser au quotidien
qu'est ce que vous pensez du fait qu'on
retrouve la même architecture dans des
mac plus dans des iphone est ce que vous
trouvez ça intéressant plutôt bien
pertinent qu'est ce que vous pensez de
l'idée de pouvoir avoir vos applications
ipad et iphone disponible directement
dans votre mac
et qu'est-ce qu'a votre avis ça laisse
entrapercevoir mark et moi ça en bas en
commentaire moi personnellement je suis
conquis sa très bien et j'ai hâte de
voir le line up d'apple en 2021 parce
que là cette année ils ont fait une
explosion à saint croyable agents non
sans plus un nouveau casque je pas si
vous avez vu c'est le airpod max un truc
assez incroyable 621 euros si je dis pas
de bêtises on est mort c'est très
onéreux
la promesse est là à voir si apple la
tiens on en reparlera également début
2000 vingt ans parce que je testerai ce
casque en 2020 apple a vraiment frappé
fort pas moins de cinq nouveaux iphone
renouvellement de l'ipad r l'ipad pour
continuer à évoluer l'aipac de huitième
génération l'apple watch séries6 l'apple
watch est ce là une nouvelle puce ils
ont vraiment mis la barre un hyper hot
en 2020 j'ai hâte de voir ce que nous
réserve apple en 2021
sur ce je vous embrasse beaucoup d'amour
monde et à très vite
[Musique]
à
bestial